[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
cancer garantir l'accès aux nouveaux
traitements
les cancers ont été responsables de 10
millions de morts dans le monde en 2019
et cette pathologie est la première
cause de mortalité prématurée en France
de nouveaux traitements ont permis des
progrès pour la survie des patients mais
ils sont de plus en plus coûteux dans
une note scientifique rédigée au nom de
l'OPEX l'Office Parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et technologiques Philippe
Bertha député et leur darkos sénatrice
présente une synthèse des dernières
avancées thérapeutiques en oncologie
sur cette base les deux parlementaires
formulent plusieurs propositions en vue
de consolider la recherche contre le
cancer et de garantir l'accès à tous les
patients au traitement les plus
efficaces en premier lieu l'opexte fait
la synthèse des évolutions médicales
récentes une médecine de précision
récemment mise au point offre des
traitements sur mesure basés sur les
spécificités moléculaires du cancer de
chaque patient il s'agit des thérapies
ciblées des thérapies cellulaires et des
thérapies par inhibiteurs de points de
contrôle immunitaire et anticorps
multi-spécifiques il existe aussi
désormais des vaccins curatifs des tests
diagnostiques permettent d'identifier
ces spécificités et de guider le choix
du traitement le plus adapté
malgré ses avancées porteuses d'espoir
lopexte constate que la personnalisation
des traitements tant à transformer les
cancers en une somme de maladies rares
ce qui entraîne une hausse significative
d’écouterrapeutiques de plus l'accès à
certains tests diagnostics essentiels
restent limités en outre des pénuries de
médicaments cruciaux surviennent
conséquence des disparités sociales se
creusent en matière d'accès au
traitement contre le cancer dans ce
contexte difficile la France subit en
outre un déclassement international en
matière de recherche encologique faute
de financement suffisant
parallèlement le coût croissant des
traitements risque d'affecter
l'équilibre financier de son système de
protection sociale
il apparaît essentiel de financer le
développement de traitement innovant en
France depuis la recherche fondamentale
jusqu'à l'industrialisation tout en
favorisant les collaborations entre
secteurs publics et privés soutient
l'OPEX
parmi ces recommandations l'Office
Parlementaire encourage le fait de
développer la disponibilité des tests
diagnostiques indispensables pour la
médecine de précision et veut permettre
leur remboursement dans cette optique
l'Office souhaite notamment une réforme
de l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie allant dans le sens
d'une gestion sur plusieurs années des
dépenses liées aux médicaments innovants
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]